تغطي رحلة بدون توقف بين اليابان
وكاليفورنيا حوالي 5500 ميل
وتستغرق ما بين 10
و 12 ساعة ، ولكن قد
تستغرق ثلاث ساعات فقط إذا خرجت طائرة آريون as3 من
الأرض ،
فهذا مفهوم لطائرة ركاب
يمكن أن تسافر أسرع من ماخ.
4 3800 ميل في الساعة لم يتم
بناؤها بعد ،
ولكن إذا حدث ذلك ، فإن صانعيها
يقولون إنه يمكن أن يحمل ما يصل إلى
50 راكبًا بسرعات تفوق سرعة الصوت
بحلول نهاية العقد ،
سيحب البعض صوت ذلك ، فمن
السهل رؤيته  لماذا سيحدث هذا طفرة
في الصناعة
وربما يكون هناك بعض الضغط في المقصورة
على شركات الطيران لتتسلق أعلى وتطير
بشكل أسرع عندما تكون السماء هي الحد الأقصى
ولكن قبل أن نربط حزام الأمان ونتأكد من
أن طاولات الدرج لدينا في
وضع القفل الرأسي ،
دعنا نخرج رؤوسنا  من
السحب وخذ نفسًا عميقًا من خلال
قناع الأكسجين لدينا
لأن هذا المشروع يحتاج إلى
التحليق قبل أن نتمكن من النظر من النافذة
ورؤية المستقبل